[MUSIC]
The exact location of the place cannot be revealed
because it is subject to the highest level of information control in the country.
Good
Japan's largest and world's highest level of security
Compared to his Alcatraz prison, it's full of gaps and holes.
[Music] The
master must have tapped it.
Thank you. It's
delicious. What should I do?
My name is
5 I understand
[Music]
Chujin No. 51,
25 Boin,
No. 69,
and Prisoner No. 15
Ponies repeat songs in prisons around the world, and are low-quality, high-percent weight loss correction versions
.
[Music]
Security sings in unison.  The 11th price will change.
It's like I'm being lured in
Come on,
if there weren't any security traps ahead, my mother
would be siri No matter what kind of traps there were, we wouldn't be caught But
then ah ah, are you
okay?
3 It's
like a moving animation, and it's like a good shoot
.  Music
] This place was a child and a black child
This place is like this and uh
, this is
very common I'll
take care of
it Why
?
When I say by place, it was a gimmick to close the wall, or maybe fate was activating
something unnecessary.
[music  ]
This was a prison in Finland where it's easy to get
sleepy Data is better in this state so I fell asleep right away
New car
pr
Ah ah ah
It was a prison in the same city that seemed to have been taken down For the
time being, hai ya ya I got
caught
ani Where else?  ware
phew
pancho this high voltage point reader I thought it would be something like this iyo a t y y y see
you dropped it too thank you ha eh
If that's the case, we'll be held responsible and receive a pay cut as usual. The
836% cut will continue for three months, so we're going to live on the first day of the east.
Ohhhh
[music] The
team is raw and chan
You know it's Harappa night training
I'm going out too, right?
Yamato, who
knows the
structure of the maze.
If the path I choose is the correct one, I'll have two side dishes for tomorrow's lunch
.  The shaker that was light at that time was
returned
Ah, I was able to shape it,
okay?
Maybe it's because of the medicine I mentioned earlier,
but I can't explain it with a peculiar condition caused by medicine
[Music]
I can't see where to go even if it's an easy delivery
Several people have escaped so far  It
's like an Amazon prison, isn't
it?  There's a
useless child who's telling anyone the key that I can't open  It's not like this
I'm the key to the world I'll show you how to open a black oar I'll show you who I'm making a triumphant face
on  I had you send me something like a spectacle There are multiple layers of security Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa The
lead is this
count peeler It's
getting worse, isn't it?
Hey, it's always been that way, isn't it? Jade, you're amazing
Shabba's wind
[Applause]
Hmm, it's data, Hajime-chan
.  I can't go on
because this is the strongest prison in the history of prison
Hammer order
It's better if you touch me now and
you'll get hurt Don't start I don't want to wait for you to start dj
pot re
Ole I'm all alone I ca
n't
help it
But I can't help it-
rar
How about Garita
goo
[music]
me
?  It's the other way around, but if you make it all the way
to the final exit today, you'll set a new record.
]
ana
5 eyes ana
aname
ana
geeni
dna
head ani
[music]
amaran
ani
re
Swimming day in the middle of conversation without myself
[music]
Chief Director Diary 3056
Today  It's going to be a peaceful day Prisoner No. 15 I told the child that there was something I really wanted to talk to him
about.  Don't you feel sorry if you don't ask that question every day?
Yeah, if I get it next month, I'll pre-order
it like Team Reebok and buy it.  Suzuka There's been
a lot lately, and I've been getting a lot of car numbers,
and I'm going to
say, "
Hey, Mr.
Gil, if I pop in, I'm not going to eat you."
Don't let Matsui and others in
. You're the 6th tier of Iso's room, right?
I don't think it's a quick answer to how to slide, but 15 has a bad personality, seems to spend money roughly, and doesn't seem to be able to work.
A child with thin body hair is pink even if it's a little bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit Is
it a good thing or
not?
Hen Only a very small percentage of girls will respond to that, so don't lie.
The food here is
delicious. It's spacious and air-conditioned, so it's comfortable. I have
three meals and lead a regular and healthy life.
I'm a professional jailbreaker, but when I think about it, I can't say it.
I've come up with a nice idea I'm
going to make it orange here
,
okay?
[Music]
Eppenhaa I'm in
training
.  I thought I was going to run away,
but I lost the match with Uno-kun again.
I've seen something unbelievable It's a woman who makes a sound
What kind of feeling did the girl give birth to?
I have a hunch that there will be 13 super major companies
.
If that's decided, I'm going to visit you
me
[music]
What are you doing again
?  These people are
my brothers,
so I'm friends with them, but
please take care of your brothers.
I'm Rakujin Shizutsu with the image of the air I'm sure you're looking for a man with a smile.
Ah, the mayor's office,
mainly the watchtower is calling.
I'm the one who's going to get yelled at, so I'm going home.
Number 15, I want to talk to you.
Nothing is happening, eh,
Judas is done to the
13 prisoners, especially the 13-stick prisoner
, number 15, because
this is the son of the 610 version of the escaped species of a, which is said to be the biggest stain in this number prison
. Did you know?
I wonder if that woman forgets,
hmm, you can remove any key, no matter how high you are, ah,
then why is it that you don't remove the neck or the neck
?  But
this black wind was blown on me while I was asleep in the prison I used to go to, but
no one there knew about this
Kase.  But I couldn't remove it at all
Who installed it
But I saw it at that time
Inside, I see a zodiac figure with a scar on his neck
What might have been a dream
But deception is reality
[music]
Number 5?
I'm looking for it to be done, I'm looking for it, I'm looking for it, I'm looking for it, and it
's a accusation that restricts my freedom Even if it's a hindrance, he's the only one who can remove his black nature.
Anything, the
final point
here
rar
Let's become a princess male
[music]
1 We will prepare an overwhelming return to secular life.
Since I teamed up, there was a game to put in, but
it's like my favorite
thing, the
Seikado Grand Prix
.  Applause]
[Music]
b C'mon, yeah,
goo
me
rar
nanonano This
is the famous Namba Prison, but we, the geniuses of jailbreaking, are doing whatever we want today as well
.  Kayo
5 Unbreakable Fortress Desperate Grand Prix
me